شارك صباح اليوم رائد الفضاء الاماراتي
سلطان النيادي لقضات مذهله وجميله جدا
لكوكب الارض من محطه الفضاء الدوليه مع
متابعي على تويتر ومع الفيديو غردا
لمتابعيه وقلهم انه حبيت اشارككم معي هذه
اللحظات اللي بشوف فيها الارض لاول مره من
وحده المراقبه قبوله علامه محطه الفضاء
الدوليه خلينا نشوف اللي شافه سلطان
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
هذا وعدتكم
معاكم نشوف اول مناظر
خلونا نشوف
ثاني مشيك وكنا
[موسيقى]
يمكن وصل في الثالث من مارس برفقه فريق
مهمه
فضائيه في تاريخ العرب واللي بتمتد لي سته
اشهر وراح يشارك في تجارب علميه في عشر
مجالات حيويه طوال مده المهمه الرحله او
المهمه هذه كانت من المقرر انه تنطلق في
السابع والعشرين من فبراير لكن اذا تاجلت
بسبب عطل في المعدات الارضيه وتم اطلاق
المركبه بنجاح يوم الخميس الماضي من مركز
كندي للفضاء اللي سابع لوكاله ناسا ووصلوا
بالسلامه